welcome back to the anime culture corner
as of the time i'm recording and editing
this video there are only
there are only two days left until
attack on titan season four
i cannot wait if you're new to the
channel and don't know already i am a
manga reader and know just how exciting
this last season will be
answer today spoiler free of course i'm
going to elaborate on just what we can
expect from the last season
how crazy the plot will be the levels of
action and how it'll stack up to other
seasons
all of it here at the anime cultural
corner however before we start
if you like attack on titan or excited
to watch season 4 or like anime or manga
in general make sure to subscribe to the
channel
over 90 of you guys aren't subbed yet
and i'd appreciate the support for my
growing channel
now that we've passed that let's get
into attack on titan
season 3 already brought huge changes we
learned of the truth behind
well basically the whole world the truth
of the eldens and the marlins the
history of the island the king within
the walls the power of the founding
titan what was in the basement
a lot happened if you want to refresh
around that before watching this video i
recommend taking a look at my video on
everything you need to know before
attack on titan season 4.
as a manga reader i can safely say that
season 4 will take us on even more of a
ride than season 3 which
already all but blew our minds by the
end of it the story of attack on titan
despite being three seasons in
is once again in its baby stages because
we learned so much recently we're
essentially faced with an entirely new
conflict and dramatic shift in the show
it's gone from a fight against the
titans a battle for self-defense within
the walls
to a challenge against the entire world
it's a quest for true freedom now and
this leaves us with the number of loose
ends to
tie first we have yet to fully resolve
the beef between levi and zeke
even though levi was the clear victor in
the fight in attack on titan it's almost
always the case that being the victor
means killing your enemy
in a society revolving around killing
titans to defend oneself
this shouldn't come as a surprise that
levi isn't done yet with zeke
after what zeke did to the rest of the
survey corpse and the loss of irwin
we're just waiting for that sweet
revenge and
expecting our top titan killer levi to
do the job
but the trailer actually brought us a
very interesting levi's scene that many
might have just glossed over
levi was killing a bunch of titans as
per usual by the end of season 4 the
scout regiment had already killed just
about all of the mindless titans on
paradise island
and considering the trailer also shows a
bunch of mindless titans falling out of
the sky
and that marlins seem to have blimps the
titans that levi's killing in the
trailer are almost guaranteed to be some
kind of new batch
this means that at some point in season
4 we're likely going to see some kind of
mass injection occur probably by the
marlians i mean they already have the
means of making titans
so this might be some way for the more
lanes to defend themselves by using ldns
and forcing them to become mindless
titans
also aaron's plans for marley will be
fundamental in driving season 4's plot
i explained this in depth in my recent
video about aaron's end goal and attack
on titan and to make a long story short
there's going to be serious conflicts
between marley and aldeans from the
walls
now that our protagonists know the
history of the world and the constant
threat that marlene's play to their
safety the declaration of war that we
saw in the trailer
is certainly not an understatement and
of course this means that we're going to
see a bunch of great action as well
even though aaron and co won the last
fight marley still has the armored cart
jaw beast and another mystery titan
under their belt
so we'll definitely see some great titan
on titan action and it's looking like it
won't just be between aaron and reiner
for a change
though we're still definitely going to
see some of that
but that brings up another problem the
last of the nine titans that we don't
know yet
every titan except for this one was
present on the island during the battle
of shikon china
even if annie was just crystallized
somewhere within the walls
what is this last titan's identity and
why were they not required on paradise
island everything from their specific
abilities to their overall strength
against aaron is unknown
and we definitely have to be on the
lookout for when this titan will appear
and how it'll go down
considering he's now beat both reiner
and annie in hand-to-hand combat
aaron's titan form is certainly the best
one-on-one fighter that we've seen so
far
will the last titan change this balance
if it's saved for last
i sure hope so
we also see in the trailer that reiner
feels extremely guilty for what he's
done
i mean with the combo of betraying his
friends and survivors guilt from
shinkansina
it's really not surprising resolving his
storyline seeing where his priorities
lie now that he has a guilty conscience
it might be time for rhino's redemption
arc but also the trailer showed us that
they're searching for a new host of the
armored titan
we aren't yet sure of how involved
reiner will be with the rest of the
series
for example if he passes his titan early
in season four
if he has survivor's guilt it's very
possible that he'll want to die and pass
on his titan as soon as possible and
his own kind of suicide attempt though i
don't think this would be a very fitting
end for reiner just considering how
big of a character he is to this series
and speaking of survivor's guilt we've
gotta look at armin too
armand saw some kind of vision before he
woke up after the battle of shiganshina
involving berthold's memories
the colossal titan was crying and saying
help me in this scene
and in the trailer we also saw that
armin was sitting in front of annie's
hard and comatose self
we have to question will armin begin to
sympathize with reiner and annie
sympathize with the enemy because of his
memories from bertholds
if this happens i feel like this might
lead to conflicts between armin
and the seemingly adamant anti-marley
and aaron this will also probably tie
into andy's future as well
i can't imagine she'll stay crystallized
until the end of the series
and so if she's gonna escape somehow i
feel like armin might be the secret key
to helping her
and the last important factor to look
out for but certainly not least is
whether aaron will unlock the abilities
of the founding titan we know he has to
make contact with the royal family
member to do it
so it's very likely that plans to use
this power will either involve historia
or zeke the only people left with royal
blood in the series
and considering the mystery surrounding
aaron krueger and his knowledge of armin
and mikasa before they were born
means that there's still more to see
from aaron's attack titan powers we can
expect the true powers of both the
attack titan and the founding titan to
be revealed here
do i think the hype's worth it
definitely map was on animation
and the anime adaptation of attack on
titan has been nothing but amazing so
far
though this season will probably be
split into parts considering the manga
isn't even done yet
at the rate it's going the manga will
likely finish in a couple months
but considering the anime's weekly a
break might be needed to allow the
original course material to finish
before the anime can finish as well
regardless though i'm sure that attack
on titan season 4 will be the anime to
watch out for in 2021
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]
you